[Music]
dee
n me
emea
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this is the head and the
body is like this and the legs are like this
That's
why it's a proof that there's nothing in the family, such as something that's half-eaten or something that's been drunk. It
feels like there was something like the United Nations that lives normally.
2 10 days after death  It's been discovered in
10 days, so it's a
bit of a problem if it doesn't work, but
maybe it's a neighborhood
, so I think I didn't contact Kamiki so often because I'm
going to receive inheritance.  Even if you look at it, you probably have a
lot of
life,
just saying that you are eating what you bought, and I think
that life was
awkward because there
was nothing.  But I
have it
net
Well, of course, it's gone and it's going to be left as it is
, so it's
an image that it's hard to flow under
it and start eating.  I'm left
dea Hmm
Alpha
I've been doing this job for 10 years, but
I think the number of lonely deaths has increased considerably.
Normally
, it's calculated that 3 people belong to each hour.
The community is good
arrow Arrow
Imai Today, the book is so thin that the
discovery is delayed and the smell is ah ah.
Well, my body is rotten and I get a lot of smell.
The specialty here is a delicious dish.
Gratan Tonkatsu Kasuju This is very popular right
now.
[Applause]
Yes,
I don't know Asai, I remember the most.
I don't have a line to go to.
Right now, I'm 0
elderly people
.
Well, 30 people at a
time, 24 hours a day, 32 performances at a lot on the cover
.  Is
n't it lonely to come to Yamato City, such as the customers of the
table
?  I don't come with obi and food anymore
. I wonder what happened to the orange-colored rim.
If you
set it up, your daughter will be
Nisakana, and you'll be alone, such as your brother.
Yes, you'll call 6 and you'll be able to draw Azaku 7.
A  But when I hear it, I'm hungry. When I want to cry, I
'll cry. I'm not
crying.
You can do
it
, not just the line, but
yeah yeah
[music]
ki nao a
little state I'm yeah yeah
yeah
[music]
Yes, that
day-hired worker and the elderly who retired from it are overwhelming in the drinking area  At most,
49.1% of the people are 65 years old or older.
Japan's behavioral growth on the net During the high-growth period of the 1960s and 1970s,
more and more workers were gathered due to labor shortages.  It's been since the 90's because I'm involved in work. If
that kind of
work is gradually decreasing, then I'm polishing here alone as that worker, so I'm not coming with my
family, but
working with my family.  I'm out of work, and when I'm working here as a worker
, I'm getting older and I'm
alone.
I'd like to introduce you
to the flexibility exercises of the hip
joint so that you can wait for your impressions.
After all, it's medical 10 days. I'm saying at home until it gets very bad because there is almost no connection with the surroundings
.
I think that it may be carried but it remains collapsed and will be discovered later. Early in the morning I
don't know much about the complex mud.
I think there are many
goo
.
There was also a person who entered, but it was different. Only during the day, the
highway is a
little hey, the miscellaneous guys are gone, but yes, that
's the tax of Orietta in 1 u living.
I was calling from the person on the
label, so I'm used to it, but how long have I been cut off?
First, it's fine.
That's why I bought it for hunting.
Yes, it smells a little and has a shift, isn't it? It's
huge, isn't it?
Every time a good phone rings,
I'm glad
if I get a phone call for 2 years at work, but it's a
strange and complicated feeling. In the summer,
I'm about 3 years old from the fashion blog.
Reyana This is normal.
Finally, I didn't regret the choice.
Baseball
Income
3 Fear of falling
or convenient wallet
[Music]
Congratulations
ppap I was
here
to put it on the market by recycling and it is in the interest of the house  The
point is that you buy it and
bring it to you.
The vendor is coming to pick it up now.
Nakata weighs 3 cycles and packs this
and brings it to you first.  This is the
one
that becomes
There are times when I don't want to get tired
of it.
The production was too much for the production site. Well, the point
was that I was a fat person with body fluids and oil.
When I think I'm going home after work, there's a light, but I'm
going to see where my
kids are.  I've been saying it for a long time, so everyone is reluctant to leave it as it
is,
so by having them worship once here, we're
still doing this by joining hands, and after we've piled up, we're also communicating
.
Hmm
[Music]
Uuu
me The
person who goes from the devil is also
a man of about 80 years old
and lives alone.
It feels like I'm getting a lot of money about once a week, isn't it? I'm
told that my relatives haven't contacted me so much,
but I don't know the details right now, but
there aren't many people around me who support me anyway.
Hmmm, I can't do it once, so I can visit it several times and put it in the front door, and if it's said that I can't get rid of it for days, I can
write it, but I died inside.  It's also possible that I was there,
Oops
Rata-san, I
have it. I'm sure the
visitor isn't good. It's a
little better to hit
it again.
Horror 6's la yeah
, it's a little worse than before, it's terrible,
dj,
it's up to here.
Actually, it's
yaro yeah
bejean
Map bing Vertical and horizontal It's a
child The
members are chewy with the past agent j
This is the image of the Diet
[Music]
Please run away to escape
It's good-
it's okay if I meet at the end I
haven't had it for about 5 years.
Te tano
Hey
al
me
If everyone decides to become a moco major, parents are worried, isn't it? He's a
man, isn't
he?  Even if I started working,
my grandma thinks 7
so I ca
n't go to the ship
anymore.  I was sick, but I was
so sad that I couldn't get rid of it,
but
I just saw that it was just a form of putting away the torch.
Well, my grandma led me to that kind of image for the child who could
n't do anything about it.
I wonder if I've managed to help those people before saying that there are people who are in trouble.
Well, I'm already breathing in that kind of thing.
]
Well 10 Well, it's construction work. I'm talking about 10 people in Tokyo, but it
's always working until I tell
you.
-16 I haven't decided yet
, I don't remember how much the tax affairs are
for my daughter.
I wouldn't buy it, but it's already a few minutes
[music]
Hey,
I
often broke it back and forth,
so I tried to draw a card
and make it a woman
.
Talk to the mayor who keeps sniffing Gratan Ne Ship
Early
me
[Music]
me Ne Air High is America Yes
I can live in my house I
'm watching TV
This is a
little stop I'm telling you to make a high-end
os Saiba
Yonera of fate  I think the staff at the store is 2 wins, 3 places, Taketsuru 1, but I
wonder if all the baby boomers have become polite Hatada.
I wonder if that loneliness or old-
fashioned Hawaii will go through
[Music]
There
is no contact as to whether anyone was there or
Maka Maka It seems like I am, but the nuclear family will support me in the new world
Gradually
Otani is good with the Articles of Incorporation of the Battle of the Temple, and the children
are no
longer waving their parents' members.
I
don't think I'm getting stronger tomorrow. I don't need it.
4th place after that 5
goo
At the Atomic Bomb Security, I'll go around here for a while and take tatami mats, so
I'll continue to do it from there.  So thank you.
[Music]
Hey, you're standing up, right?
He's got him after all, and he
's got a day later.
But
I have an image of hearing a voiceless voice.
I wonder what kind of result the length was, and I wonder if it was such a feeling while looking at it.
While looking at the message and that kind of thing, I was thinking like that. I
'm really listening to that feeling.
I'm checking if the mouth is quite in the youth
.
After all, it is an operation that makes it a decision to have the photograph taken home, so
please return it in advance
.
I feel sorry for the fact that I'm sorry for the fact that I'm going
to clean it from now on
.  And sugar plate
big earthquake
Audi tongue is still dark sound Body Jitter
is also Dada and 3
ni
Upper building Originally
I still think that commemorative maintenance is not something to ask a contractor
Originally Family 0
After all, memories of the old days  I want
you to be in a place like that, thank you for giving birth to a moving mother.
Originally, it can't be done for various reasons anymore, so it's a reality that our industry is now,
but it's a
heavy life.
I think it's only when the fire spirits feel that the drama is wonderful. Of course, the funeral is physical from the outside.  If it's negative by farewell,
I think it's like he's spiritual, but by chance on live I have to think about
it when I'm really gone and my heart really feels like I'm inside.
I don't come when I think about it
[Music]